ah march  well of course around here it's still  freezing it's actually snowing uh as i  record this got a new set of monthly  bills to deal with but also later on  this month it's my birthday  i'm turning 40.  if you feel like doing anything you'll  find various links below  my patreon could always use a boost  there's other ways to support me as well  my amazon wishlist if that is more your  speed you'll also find my p.o box if you  really want to go for something  personalized but  even if you're just watching this all  the way through  i appreciate that too  hope you have a good month  and uh hope you enjoy  your next birthday whenever that comes  around  40.